I also watched um
I wish you knew Avatar
oh the movie yeah I want to watch that
is it worth it how was it long yeah
it's like three and a half hours long
it's it's so long yeah it doesn't feel
long yes yes I fell asleep uh
but I woke up and I felt like I didn't
miss anything so that's also I heard
it's just the same story as the first
movie but just it's underwater now it's
the water people man the next movie is
the fire people so he's one element away
from a lawsuit he's got to be careful
yeah the fourth one I know they've
already filmed it I I he can't be doing
all four elements I mean no he I think
he has filmed all of them yes yes but if
he can't do all four elements surely I
mean that's yeah and apparently the
final like the bad people in this one
too I feel like come on and then
eventually Jake Sully is gonna have a
[ __ ] arrow on his head and start
floating around so listen I I watched
Avatar and I watched it in this I
watched it in Canada
um I watched it in this weird
um I've never seen this before it's like
some kind of like the main screen and
then the walls have a projector where it
extends the screen so like there's more
stuff like a curved screen no no no like
a wall yeah and then the two side walls
are projected and there's just more off
of the screen I don't know what this is
called can we google this what yeah like
an old like an ultra wide screen no it's
not a screen it's literally just the
walls but they're like projecting like
more of the screen uh I must imagine
like this like this is the set of trash
taste right yeah this is the screen what
you'd normally see and then there's just
like all of this that you don't see
right they've just projected that on the
walls oh it's weird it's not like zoomed
in or anything it's like so is this
stuff happening on the sides
like background stuff oh so it's kind of
like it's kind of like adding to these I
think he's just trying to immerse you it
was really [ __ ] right I don't think it's
very weird like it's like you go from
this like 800k display to like Blurry
wall like it's kind of it's kind of a
shooting projection yeah it's kind of
[ __ ] I really like it I I heard see
because I haven't seen it yet but I've
heard a lot of people talking about it
and like kind of giving their like
criticisms and stuff like that well for
one it's like too long um and two I
heard that like they shot it at a
different frame rate right I don't know
I think apparently the second can you
look this up but like apparently from
whatever from a couple of my friends
yeah oh so Joey
according to my gamer friends they were
saying that like apparently now this one
instead of the standard cinema Standard
24 frames it's done in like 49 frames or
something but 48 so some Cinemas that
don't support the 48 frames it just
makes the movie look like [ __ ] right and
it's kind of and it's kind of like again
like please confirm this but like yeah
it is right so it's like so if you go to
a cinema that supports 48 frames then it
doesn't make it any better because it
kind of is the same vibe in my head it's
kind of the same Vibe as like you know
watching like 60 frames per second anime
this looks a little like okay it's like
a little too smooth no no there there is
a difference between 60 frames per
second anime and a movie that was
intentionally shot at a certain frame
rate right because 60 frame of 60 frames
per second anime isn't actually 60
frames per second anime it's at 24
frames per second but someone's put it
through a [ __ ] After Effects filter
yeah to interpolate the frames so it
looks like [ __ ] [ __ ] please stop
doing that to animation oh my God it's
like my biggest [ __ ] stuff all the
time it has not died really I haven't
seen it in a while okay every time I
want to like search up a cool anime
fight or like an anime opening on
YouTube the 4K 60fps the top results is
never actually the original [ __ ] seed
it's always interpolated and I'm not
saying like all interpolation looks bad
there are some like amvs and there are
some edits that can make really good use
of the interpolation effect but you
can't just put an entire [ __ ] scene
through that and think that it's all
going to translate well it just ruins
the entire scene to me and it just it
it's all right yeah even though I guess
like the concept or like you know the
the transition from the original source
is different like it's kind of from what
I heard from a couple of my friends it's
kind of that same feeling I'm like
because you're so used to watching it in
24 frames like you know like you know
cinematic films when you watch it at
Double the frame rate it's like oh it's
like the first time you watched 60
frames per second YouTube it's just like
oh this is really smooth to the point
where it's kind of uncomfortable yeah
and like I don't know I don't know what
James Cameron's in you know like idea
for that was he's obviously trying to
like push Cinema in different ways right
but it's like
I don't know if that was the right move
frames yeah it's like I don't know if
more frames if that's true I don't think
that's the first film that's done that
because I'm sure it's not but like at
the same time it's like was it Hobbit or
something that also did the same thing
that like filmed at a high frame rate
and people there was this disconnect
where it like some of the feedback that
was given was people who weren't just
just weren't used to seeing films in a
high frame rate did you notice the
difference when you watched the Avatar
movie uh no
um I don't think so it just looked like
a standard 24. yeah man bro it was it
was good
um I just wish it wasn't that long it
was really really long all right
um it's just was it a good film I would
say yes but I don't think it's a great
level I've never seen someone that's so
confused about because experience with
the film on one hand I'm like you know I
fell asleep for like 20 30 minutes at
one point and I felt like I missed
nothing when I woke up I felt like I I
knew exactly what what I'd kind of
missed well for one falling asleep in a
film is
it was just like you can't fall asleep
for like a fifth of the film and being
like I think it was a good film no I
think when I was awake and like
technically speaking like it's a [ __ ]
Master Class like it looks insane yeah
it is stunning yeah but also it you know
I mean Avatar won I do watch Avatar one
yeah well you've seen Avatar one and I
kind of felt that it didn't really
expand upon it in a way that I was kind
of hoping
um you know Avatar one was never about
like the storyline Avatar one is just
Pocahontas in space right but like how
do you how do you make then a sequel to
a story that wasn't even that really
impactful did you like Avatar one I
liked Avatar one I thought as a as it
was it wasn't like crazy long yeah I did
what it needed to do it told the story
and at the time it was like technically
groundbreaking it was good yeah I think
it was made Avatar one entertain
attaining at least for me at the time
was the fact that compared to other yeah
ever compared to other like film you
know cinematic like big cinematic films
at the time I think its strongest point
was definitely just like how insane like
the the CG was right oh like the the
visual it's it's even the visual
elements right yeah but like I feel now
I think the reason why people aren't
talking about it as much with this
second film is because now there's a lot
of like you know like MCU films and like
big cinematic films that uh probably at
the same quality if not you know a
similar quality to what Avatar 2 might
have again this come from someone who
hasn't seen the film just I mean
technically looks way better than any of
any MCD films did it did it like give
you okay here's the thing about Avatar
one which I'll never forget
um even though I've forgotten like I've
forgotten everything I've forgotten like
most of like the story and characters
yeah it's what I'm is what I was trying
to say but I will never forget the
experience of watching Avatar one for
the first I'm in cinemas because I
remember being blown away by the
experience and the visual effects yeah
and that's that that feeling has still
never been eclipsed in like Cinemas for
me uh even watching like end game or
stuff like that like it's never eclipsed
the first time seeing Avatar one in
cinemas being like holy [ __ ] CGI and
films can look this good yeah it is it
is like a step up again yeah you think
you're like how could it look better
than the first was it what was it again
it was like it's the underwater CG right
it's like the selling there's a lot of
like I mean there's the whole [ __ ]
film's water right and it's it's cool I
just think the problem is I just like um
because obviously if you remember the
first film it was Jake Sully was the
main character yeah
um I dude man something I'm racist
against Blue people but dude I I had
such a hard time in the start of the
movie figuring out who the [ __ ] was who
um I guess because it's like it's it's
all all these blue people look the
[ __ ] same like all these because it's
the whole movie is basically from the
perspective of like avatars yeah yeah
and the navi yeah the navi and you just
kind of like for a while you're like I
don't [ __ ] care like like I don't
care about Jake Sully's kids I like and
then I I just I think that was the
problem is that we hadn't obviously
because it's been so long and the story
is like many many years in the future
you're introducing these characters
you've never met I don't [ __ ]
particularly like the kids that much and
I just kind of thought God damn man can
I just like can we just do something
else I just have like a different
character I don't remember one thing I
kept seeing on like Tick Tock especially
is just like these like weird fan cams
for like Jake Sully and Avatar too
because he's like because unlike in the
first film in the second film he's like
a dad now yeah right and he's like and
there's like this like weird group of
people on Tick Tock that I've seen of
like people making fan cams with Jake
Sully as being like kind of like a dilf
material yeah and this is like I saw
this one of like this girl freaking out
because in one scene I guess in Avatar
too Jake Sully goes like what's up baby
girl
well I just people
hold like dope side of things just like
just like oh my God he's so hot and I'm
like we definitely didn't have that in
Avatar BTS I sleep now Jake Sully Sully
as a deal
they did this really one really cool
thing where uh Jake Sully is uh so
before this happens in the film when
they're talking about vehicle subtitles
and then one scene he goes like oh yeah
it's like English to me now because he's
like talked about how he became so
native yeah yeah and as he says that we
start hearing the native language in
English
and the rest of the film it's all in
English when they speak in like that oh
is that like cool transition I thought
that was pretty cool that's a really
cool way of handling how you have this
language and kind of getting over it and
making it I guess people don't want to
because otherwise the whole movie would
be Savvy subtitles I guess people don't
want to sit through three and a half
hours of subtitles oh dog yeah man I
could not sit through that yeah
we can never do that who would want to
do that
I guess just when it's a made-up
language you're like why just just put
it in a [ __ ] language yeah I guess I
get it you want to build the world up
but it's like if it's like three hours
you're like yeah that's that's a bit too
much is the World building that am I
Really Gonna Be that did the visuals
blow you away as much as seeing Avatar
one for the first time I mean I was so
young when I watched Avatar one I can't
yeah I don't really remember I mean I I
you know when I was sitting there
watching it I was very impressed I'll
say that much like you can't not notice
how insane it looks yeah yeah
um I mean even just watching the
trailers it's like oh [ __ ] yeah yeah and
again it's one of those movies that if
you haven't I'd recommend going checking
out at theaters yeah okay because
because like it'd be a shame to watch it
at home yeah I mean from the trailers
alone it looks insane but I don't know
if it's me getting old or if it's just
technology reaching kind of like it's
April looks really good in general
nowadays yeah yeah because because it's
similar to what's going on with like
video gaming right now right where I
remember you know growing up playing
like the Super Nintendo and then
scanning an N64 for the first time and
seeing that jump from 2D to 3D it was
[ __ ] insane yeah it blew my mind kids
today will never be able to feel that
and then like going from like Mario 64
to seeing like the visual Improvement
into Mario Sunshine yeah that was like
[ __ ] insane and yeah and then like
and now you can see Mario's Paws it's
like technology improves I'm like I'm
looking at let's say uh I remember
playing the original Last of Us I know I
see like the remaster and I'm like
What's the what's what's the difference
I don't I don't I don't see it and I'm I
look at Avatar too just the trailers I
haven't seen the film I look at Avatar
too and I'm like this looks fantastic
but I look at Avatar one and I'm like
this still looks fantastic right and I
don't know if I'll ever get that same
wow moment like how much better could we
get to the point where it actually makes
a like a discernible difference yeah
instantly recognizable exactly I mean I
was still more Blown Away by you know
Masterpiece that hentai that was
definitely more visually impressive
speaking of which the third one's coming
out this month and I'm very excited oh
really are they clear they bringing it
back they're bringing it back Avatar
through I sleep
in my calendar
I've called up Kleenex I'm like send it
all send everything
the blue light
I I mean let's yeah it's fine I think uh
I'm I don't know how Avatar three and
four are gonna be interesting enough to
keep everyone yeah because I heard that
Avatar 2 didn't really do that great box
office wise I I could be compared to
Avatar one or just in general uh in
general like in the market yeah you need
to you know make a lot more money in
cinema today to make it more viable for
sure yeah and especially with the amount
of money and time he sank into it
I just I because I feel bad for the guy
if he if he wouldn't be able to like
finish the vision he had for it because
I do want to see how it ends though like
I think it's a it's a cool enough world
where uh and he's he's such a good
filmmaker James Cameron in general where
I want to see where it goes uh I just
worry that it didn't do well enough and
if the third one doesn't do well yeah
like what you know is he gonna is he
gonna be like fine I'll do it myself
I'll bankroll it like like what's gonna
because he he's a crazy guy yeah he is a
[ __ ] insane guy
um especially when it comes to the art
filmmaking as well um he definitely
pushes the boundary sure um one thing
that really surprised me about Avatar
too was how little I heard about it
before it actually came out I just yeah
I didn't I didn't know it was out until
it came out you know normally I remember
Avatar one came out came out when that
came out it was this [ __ ] hyped thing
this hyped movie that completely
revolutionized digital technology in
films and it did at the time you know it
was also like that kind of kicked off
like what a very big wave of 3D yeah
that's why we have 3D cinemas still
stuck with us the garbage yeah yeah but
like I I'd heard nothing about Avatar 2
before and I don't know if it was it's
just me not being as involved in like
the film industry or anything like that
or like even less but even still it was
like I wasn't necessarily in that
Community when Avatar one came out but
it was like inescapable like everyone
was talking about that film like so much
so to the point where everyone was like
they made it like their job to just go
and watch it and you know regardless of
whether you enjoyed it or not but this
one it's like yeah I don't know maybe
it's because like the the the the
environment of like you know movies
being promoted and stuff like that has
changed over the years since Avatar one
came out but like yeah same thing it's
like I found out about the trailer
because I saw it on YouTube and I'm like
oh this trailer came out a week ago and
I hadn't heard about it yeah like I knew
it was coming but I didn't know when it
was coming I didn't even know look I I
had heard that in the Woodworks that
there was like an Avatar 2 being made
yeah and then my next my next news about
Avatar 2 is that it's out I was like
what what this was in production this
entire time well I like I had more
information about [ __ ] Dune coming
out before then you know I think people
were pretty excited about it um it was
weird it was really scattered online it
wasn't like this one big push the
marketing wasn't crazy for it either
yeah um I think that was probably
because they were just banking off the
fact that it's like everyone's seen
Avatar yeah maybe I don't know I wonder
what it was I I either way I mean I hope
it does well enough to to come back for
a third and fourth I hopefully won't
fall asleep next time I just think it
was too damn long it was too damn long
fell asleep seven hours seven eight
hours
I didn't okay too fair that day I was
very tired and I felt like I would have
fallen asleep in most movies unless they
were like insane all right that day
particularly it just hurt Avatar that it
was just kind of like hey
that's just like a lot going on and in
the middle my God does the film feel so
[ __ ] slow right because you know the
start's kind of really engaging is a lot
happening and in the end there's this
giant like you know [ __ ] seeing the
battle that goes on for like 40 50
minutes of course Jesus and it's a
really impressive and cool but even that
felt like hey come on can we like can we
yeah
it felt like I've shown him because like
something would happen and then it'd be
defeated and then of course there's
another like but he's getting back up or
right oh but this guy's coming back and
it's like what the [ __ ] man I like to
call it the nanny moments yeah yeah just
like what I'm talking about don't not
wanting to commit like entertainment
because like I I wanted to watch Avatar
too because like I said it looks
beautiful but yeah the thought of having
to go to the cinema and sit down for
like two and a half two and a half three
hours I'm like maybe I'll do it tomorrow
Tomorrow Comes
ah maybe maybe like the day after you
know I'll I'll get some time and then I
know if I don't watch Avatar 2 in
cinemas I'm not gonna watch it on like
on the small screen yes there's no point
there's no point in my mind so the
clock's ticking
how much longer is it out it was like a
week or two I can't imagine it'd be too
much oh [ __ ] all right I gotta make some
time then yeah watch it it's definitely
an experience it is an experience there
are a lot of things like getting your
balls castrated it's brilliant
experience I was asleep for 30 minutes
I imagine her stomach flu is an
experiences that was an experience for
sure I was asleep for most of that and
that was like a two out of ten so I
might like Avatar I enjoy it Avatar too
it's kind of like getting stomach flu
sleep through most of it and then you
just you know it's a majority of it is
painful and you sleep through some of it
because I feel well rested for the year
coming up oh my God yeah because I mean
before this episode we were you know
because you know this is our first day
back in the off office
um and so we obviously had to figure out
what our schedules were for this year
and uh
just tldr it's [ __ ]
but which is good you know we're keeping
ourselves busy